saying those talks failed those strikes
will go ahead oh hello
hello there
so as you can see it's all set up to go
for that um press conference as soon as
the rmt union get out behind those bikes
we'll bring that to you in the meantime
let's go to ukraine though because
russia has appeared to have made small
gains in the slow battle for the
strategic city of donetsk southeast of
the country's second biggest city
kharkiv but russia continues to face
sanctions from europe the kremlin has
called lithuania's newest ban on the
transit of goods to russia's kaliningrad
region an openly hostile and
unprecedented situation our
correspondent john sparks has the latest
from ukraine
there is a flash point there a mark or a
point of tension and that has really
broken out into the open what has
happened is that the eu is has moved to
implement a ban on the impla on the
transport of goods from russia
and we're talking about things like
metals and coal and computer technology
that sort of stuff basically that kind
of stuff is not supposed not allowed to
move into european or eu territory there
is this bit of russia this slither of
russia on the baltic sea called
kaliningrad sandwiched between poland
and lithuania there is agreement that
allows
okay let's go to houston and listen to
the rmt
come on in
right you ready
so first of all before we kick off i
just want to say public we've had
tremendous support
uh
coming in from all over the country
indeed internationally from
ordinary working people trade unionists
and their organizations and that was
shown at the rally on
uh saturday when the rmt received a
tremendous evasion from the rest of the
organized
movement in this country but
nevertheless
we're moving on now to the next phase of
this campaign
and we've been in discussions with
network rail and the train operators
almost continuously
for several weeks now and indeed for
nearly 18 months on the issues in this
dispute
and despite what grant shap said over
the weekend when he was fabricating
uh news items that we've walked out of
talks we've never walked out of any
talks at any stage in this dispute and
we remain in the room until the meeting
is properly adjourned
and that to be fair to the companies we
have kept up
called your relationships with the
employers all the way through this but
what we have got come to understand
is that the dead hand of this tory
government is all over this dispute
and the fingerprints of grant shaps and
the dna of rishi sunak
all over
the problems on the railway and indeed
the problems in this society and until
they allow these employers
to negotiate freely i can't see that
we're going to get a settlement
to the issues that are in front of us
so we've now had offers from network
rail
and from the train operating companies
and the executive committee in this
building
has considered those offers and they've
rejected both of them
the network rail one was rejected on
friday
and the train operating company one
which was only put to us today has been
rejected this afternoon
uh both sets of proposals are
unacceptable and it's now confirmed that
the strike action that is planned for
this week will go ahead
uh on london underground and on network
rail and with the train operating
companies
the source of this problem is the tory
government's decision to slash four
billion pounds of funding from our
railway network
they've cut two billion pounds from the
national railway
and they've cut two billion pounds from
tfl
and that is hobbling this industry and
it's forcing the companies to implement
transport austerity and massive cuts to
our system
as we speak
they've now proposed the rail companies
pay rates that are massively under the
relevant rates of inflation
they do not address the cost of living
crisis
and they have prevented a settlement to
this dispute
at the behest of the government the
companies are also seeking to implement
thousands of job cuts
across the network and have failed to
give any guarantee against compulsory
redundancies
as a result of this transport austerity
the employing companies have taken the
following decisions
to attack the railway pension scheme and
the transport for london scheme
diluting benefits making staff work
longer
up to 65 years of age
and making them poor in retirement while
paying increased contributions
they have decided to cut thousands of
jobs across the rail network
without that guarantee of no compulsory
redundancies
they are cutting safety inspections by
maintenance staff on the infrastructure
by up to 50
in order to facilitate the mass
redundancies and in maintenance that
alone that will be 3000 track workers
who are out there repairing and
maintaining the infrastructure and
looking after the public
their jobs are for the chop
they're attacking the terms and
conditions and working practices in a
form of internal
fire and re-hire
including lowering existing salaries and
increasing the working week
these attacks mean that no trade union
in this country could accept that agenda
and in fact in many ways it's similar to
what pno have put before us
either you take diluted terms or you
leave the industry
they even want to go so far as to
restart the dispute on the role and
responsibility of the guard
and they're going to put massive massive
cuts to the catering services on our
railway so we're going backwards
uh many years in fact to the cuts agenda
that we've had
under thatcher and under british rail
when that was seriously underfunded over
decades
they're going further
and have told us today and last week
that they intend to close every single
ticket office
in britain
regardless of the accessibility needs of
the public
and the diversity of the passengers that
use the railway system
they're cutting real pay for our members
and their spending power through what
are now lengthy pay
pay freezes
for nearly three years for many of our
members
and the offers that we have are way
below
the retail price index which is the
relevant
uh measure of inflation
for
us faced with such an aggressive agenda
of cuts the jobs conditions pay in
pensions
the rnt has no choice but to defend our
members
industrially and to stop this race to
the bottom
the strikes on network rail the train
operators and london underground will go
ahead
and we again call on our members
to stand firm
support the action
mount the pickets and demonstrate their
willingness to fight for workplace
justice
the rnt supports the campaign for a
square deal for all working people
in the face of the cost of living crisis
and our current campaign
is a part of that more general campaign
that means that public services have to
be properly funded and all workers paid
properly with good conditions
we remain available for discussions
during the action and after the action
and between the strike dates if the
companies want to engage with us
but we are firmly of the belief that the
only way for us to settle this dispute
is for grant shaps and the government to
allow these companies to negotiate and
let the parties reach a reasonable
agreement that will end the disruption
of the service
will secure jobs
and allow a decent transport system to
be developed in this country
thanks very much for listening
what makes your representatives so
special
well we're not special the whole country
is suffering
and we have got a membership and a trade
union that is prepared to fight for what
we've got
what the rest of the country suffers
from is the lack of power
the lack of the ability to organize and
the lack
of the wherewithal to take on these
employers that are continually driving
down wages and making the working class
in this country
poorer year on year on year
while the rich get richer
and dividends are accelerated and the
stock market is reasonably healthy we've
got full employment
we've got full employment and falling
wages and that is a situation that has
never happened before and it cannot be
tolerated by working people or by the
trade union movement
from the lack of
transport
what is your message to them
we regret that we don't want that to
happen but this dispute has been
manufactured by shafts and by government
policy there was no need for them to cut
the funding of the railway scheme and
there's no need for them to campaign
actively for job cuts pay cuts and
safety cuts and that's what they're
doing network rails says the railway
finances are already a mess do you not
think that by taking strike action like
this you risk making them even worse
well they're not a mess so let's get
this clear the railway has been uh
subsidised since time immemorial at
least since the first world war and it
probably always will be subsidised what
we're seeing now is a recovery in rail
passenger numbers are up to 90 the week
before last and it's on course to go
back to pre-covered levels but what
we're seeing here is a smoke screen
caused by covid and many employers are
taking this opportunity they're using
what is a temporary phenomenon
covid and the temporary phenomenon of
people being told not to go to work
as a smokescreen to get rid of decent
conditions decent pay rates and decent
agreements now everybody wants our
cities towns and villages to to recover
the way we do that and one of the most
important aspects of that is by having a
decent public transport system that can
be relied on is safe and accessible
cutting staff cutting services and
cutting funding is the opposite to that
and nobody in our community should
tolerate that from this government of
billionaires who tell everyone else
they've got to tighten their belts while
they're raking it in
are you supported by the labour
leadership
am i supported by the latest labour
leadership
well the labour leadership's got a
problem haven't they they've got they're
against uh workers being exploited and
they're against this tory government
they've got to find a way to connect to
working-class people in working-class
communities so they can get their votes
back so they've got to find their
message
they've got to find some policies
that get back to where working people
are we saw
many working people out on the streets
on saturday i think there's going to be
more of that and i think there's going
to be a wave of industrial action a wave
of ballots and a wave of campaigning so
kirsten and his team have got to work
out a way how they connect with that and
how they ride that wave of resistance
and are in harmony with it rather than
standing to one side waiting for
somebody to tell them what to do
the pay proposals are a two percent down
payment with the possibility of one
percent more but we have to accept their
full agenda of job cuts
changes to working practices and of
course we have to accept that we haven't
had a pay rise from our members for
three years and this is more of a
whimper than a bank there's nothing in
this that we could compromise on and i
don't think any trade union in this
country could accept what's on the table
today
well our campaign will get run for as
long as it needs to run until we get a
settlement that's acceptable to our
people whenever we get an offer that is
tenable we will put that to our members
in a referendum but what's on the table
now given the mandate that we've got
where 89 percent of our people voted in
favor of going on strike this does not
address any of the multitude of issues
that are in this uh campaign that we've
got i don't know how long that will take
i think it will take as long as the
government uh
needs to take to unshackle the companies
to negotiate with us properly
pay rise most people have not had a pay
rise at all in this country for three
years and many of the public sector
workers as well as private sector
workers have not had a proper pay rise
since osborne and the other giza cameron
whatever his name was came to power
so the idea that there is a wage price
spiral that the accelerating wages of
workers is causing
uh prices to go up is a nonsense what's
causing prices to go up is profiteering
profits in this country are not down
what is down is wages the only people
that are paying the price
of kovid are the working class of this
country so there hasn't been a wage
price spiral and there's no need to
think that there will be one by people
catching up with wages
wage prices aren't catching up with
wages
wages are trying to catch up with prices
and nobody's had 12 and nobody's asked
for 12 by the way
is that would make the railway more
efficient
no we're not we deal with working
practice changes all of the time in
every company that we deal with whether
it's a bus company a maritime company an
oil company or a railway company we
negotiate change on a permanent basis
with every one of our employers
including network rail transport for
london and the train operators
what we've got here is an unreasonable
agenda of mass pay cuts
mass job cuts and slashing of our terms
and conditions that have been negotiated
uh over a long period those are all good
conditions the problem of our conditions
is that everybody else is a worse
and the problem with some of our pay
rates is everybody else's or worse so
what we need to do is level up
and i think somebody else came up with
that quote
and what we're being forced to do
is suppress working people to deliver
government policy and profits for their
friends in the city and that's not
acceptable
there's a lot of taxpayers who might
think it's unfair to be funding pay
increases
maybe even higher percent but when
they're struggling with the cost of
living themselves what do you say to
them well those taxpayers are also
suffering with the cost of living and
many of them are working in the public
sector and they're facing pay cuts
everybody who works in in health
education care council services have all
seen pay suppression
and the only way to break that cycle is
to get paid deals that break it now all
money in circulation comes from all of
us
so somebody is paying for every service
or product that you buy
but if we have continual
price suppression you will have
continual hyper profit and there's got
to be a balance in the society between
profit and income we're not getting
enough income and they're getting too
much profit
that you're talking about here
well last year in the railway
industry
the rolling stock companies network rail
subcontractors
and the train operating companies made
500 million pounds of direct profit
that's that's a fact is in their books
last year on rail
last year on rail the first group which
is one of the major
shareholders and train operating
companies made 108 million pound out of
rail alone
they have been subject to a takeover bid
of 1.2 billion
go ahead who's one of the other
companies are also subject to a takeover
bid so somebody thinks they're going to
make profits out of rail because private
equity companies from abroad are coming
here to buy these companies
while they're managing directors are
earning millions the cheap the top
earner in network rail earned 1.2
million pounds in salary during covid
his chief financial operator uh
executive earned nearly half a million
pound each year during covid all of
these executives that we're dealing with
are on salaries in excess of three
hundred and fifty thousand pounds a year
somebody's making money out of the
railways just not our members so it
should be there should be some kind of
windfall tax like we've seen in the old
well i'd like the windfall tax to be a
windfall for our members through their
wages that would be a start someone's
gotta pay for that additional money
well we're all paying for it we'll pay
for it through the fares and we'll pay
for it for a regeneration of rail if we
can get a system that works on behalf of
the people on behalf of the economy on
behalf of the environment rather than
for private profit
not particularly because rail fares have
gone up in order to play for profits
profit since privatization has been
something around 12 billion so all of
that profit has been extracted from our
railway system if we'd use that to
invest we could have lowered the fares
we could have improved the services and
we could have had a bit a square deal
for railway workers it's the extraction
of profit from the railway system which
is largely subsidised through the
taxpayer that has caused the cause of
one of our problems so surely the answer
is
well it's not the only answer we want an
answer to our problems at this time and
the problem for our members is losing
their jobs having their conditions
ripped up and not getting a pay deal so
when we've addressed that one we can
move on to government policy
i don't know i can't answer that
question that we don't set out you know
of a project saying it's going to last
this long and if we haven't got a deal
it will be wrapped up it will go on
until somebody offers us a deal that we
can accept and we can put to our members
and they vote for it in a referendum
anyone else are we finished
good
okay thank you very much
so quite a frank mc lynch there from the
rmt union setting out their position why
they believe those talks failed they
said they had two sets of proposals and
both were unacceptable to them so the
strike goes ahead mr lynch said that
they are available for discussion so
let's bring in
our political correspondent rob powell
he's in westminster um
rob that was interesting he was very
damning wasn't he not only about grant
chaps but also rishi sunak
yeah pretty fiery stuff from mick lynch
there he's of course the general
secretary of the rmt union so the most
senior person in that union that's been
involved in those discussions that is
and is essentially overseeing the
strikes that will bring much of the
country's train services to a halt over
the coming five or six days
he said that those discussions had
broken down that payoffs had been put on
the table around two to three percent
and they had both been rejected and
found to be unacceptable he was placing
the blame squarely at the door of grant
shaps and rishi sunak he said of grant
shaps that this had the fingerprints of
grant shaps and the dna of rishi sunak
all over it and said it was the dead
hand of this tory government all over
the dispute
as well so clearly he believes the
government is not giving network rail
and not giving the rail companies which
of course the government gives a large
amount of money to the bandwidth to
increase that pay offer and is also
unhappy with what the government calls
modernizations what they call cuts that
they want to put through in the coming
months as well i thought another part of
that that would be alarming for the
government but really alarming for
anyone really that uses the trains um
repeatedly and regularly over the coming
months is mick lynch also said that he
predicted a wave of industrial action a
wave of walkouts and protests um over
the coming
months not just in rail but in other
sectors as well really re-emphasizing
what he told sky news yesterday that he
believes really the disparity between
how much pay is going up especially in
the public sector and how much prices
are going up really could bring
more of these types of strikes
in other sectors in the months ahead and
i think if that does come about this
could all get quite ugly politically for
the government quite quickly it's not
looking like a great summer is it rob
thanks a lot
now aid agency is a warning of a
humanitarian catastrophe in east africa
due to drought and the impact of the war
in ukraine the blockade of ukraine's
ports has caused a global food shortage
and a sharp increase in prices and in
countries unable to grow their own food
the result could be devastating for
millions of people now the horn of
africa is facing severe drought after
the rainy season failed for the fourth
year in a row
with somalia and the self-declared
republic of somaliland facing the worst
drought in 40 years almost 800 000
people have left their homes in the
countryside to seek help in cities a